about this uh as for you what are the  differences between online and  over-the-board chess  i think uh perhaps the biggest  difference is that a lot of players over  the board they can they can be very  quick i think a great example  is in this last game it's very quick i  think if we play this game online i mean  maybe he wouldn't  have lost some time but he would have he  would have been under a lot of pressure  much sooner i think also  uh my game against alexenko same same  kind of thing so i think online is  actually probably harder because the the  way players view the board is a little  bit different and it's it's uh it's  harder kind of the hand eye is different  as opposed to like physically moving  pieces and then clicking and clicking  i think online is online is harder so if  you're faster which i which i definitely  am i mean i think the advantage is more  or now so i think i'm actually better  online  thank you very much